herzlich willkommen bei ZDF heute live
schön dass ihr dabei seid wir blicken
heute gemeinsam auf den Besuch des
türkischen Präsidenten rejb tayib
Erdogan der zu seinem ersten
Deutschlandbesuch seit 3 Jahren in
Berlin eingetroffen ist begleitet von
vereinzelen Protesten und unter hohen
Sicherheitsvorkehrung in der Stadt hatte
Erdogan zunächst Bundespräsident
Steinmeier besucht der ihn auf Schloss
belvue in empfangnahmen da sehen wir die
Bilder von heute Nachmittag das war
gegen Z 15 Uhr und jetzt gleich steht
noch eine pressebegegnung an im
Kanzleramt gemeinsam mit Bundeskanzler
Olaf Scholz und bei der sind wir hier
heute mit ZDF heute live wie der Name
schon sagt live dabei da seht ihr die
Bilder und Themen dieser Gespräche im
Kanzleramt die sind nach der
pressebegegnung sollen unter anderem der
Krieg in der Ost und das migration
Abkommen zwischen der EU und Ankara sein
dieser Besuch Erdogans wird auch von
starker Kritik begleitet der türkische
Staatschef hatte zuletzt immer
vehementer Kritik an Israels
Vorgehen geleistet oder hatte das
Vorgehen Israels kritisiert dabei das
Land sogar als Zitat Terrorstaat
bezeichnet über diese pressebegegnung
und über erdohans Bedeutung in den ganz
großen geopolitischen Fragen dieser Zeit
möchten wir heute sprechen und wir
fragen uns dabei gibt es keine roten
Linien für Erdogan das bespreche ich wie
immer nicht alleine sondern zum einen
mit Hauptstadt Korrespondent dominikbka
in Berlin und mit David Bartel das ist
der Leiter des türkeibüros der Heinrich
bstiftung und wie immer hier in unserem
Format auch mit euch da draußen wenn ihr
fragen habt zu dem was Scholz was
Erdogan gleich bei dieser
pressebegegnung sagen werden oder
generell zum Thema oder ihr wollt
einfach eure Meinung mit uns teilen dann
schreibt uns se gerne hier direkt bei
Youtube oder Mail an die unten
eingeblendete Adresse jetzt möchte ich
aber erstmal über die Vorzeichen
sprechen unter denen dieser Besuch steht
und das mache ich gemeinsam mit
hauptstadtkorrespondent Dominik ritbka
der uns jetzt live aus Berlin
zugeschaltet ist guten Abend Dominik
hallo Victoria grüß Dich Dominik was
erwartet man sich denn in der Hauptstadt
von diesem Besuch Erdogans seit dem
letzten Besuch vor dre Jahren ist ja
einiges passiert ja und es gibt viele
sehr schwierige Themen die auf der
Agenda stehen das migrationsabkommen du
hast es schon gesagt bekommt die Türkei
Geld dafür dass Flüchtlinge nicht mehr
nach Europa gehen dass auch Flüchtlinge
zurück nach griechenchenland geschickt
werden z.B eine Verlängerung dieses
Abkommens ist ein mögliches Thema und
dann werden wir sicherlich auch darüber
sprechen wie der ukrainekrieg aussit ich
muss dich einmal unterbrechen es geht
nämlich schon los wir sprechen uns
danach noch mal hier also die
pressebegegnung mit Kanzler
schz ich begrüße den türkischen
Staatspräsidenten hier in Berlin es ist
gut Herr Präsident dass wir die
Gelegenheit haben werden direkt
miteinander zu sprechen uns beschäftigen
beide die Krisen in dieser Welt da ist
zunächst der russische Überfall auf die
Ukraine und seine weitreichenden Folgen
unter denen fast die ganze Welt zu
leiden hat wir beide sind uns einig
Russland muss seine Aggression so
schnell wie möglich
beenden die Türkei hat eine konstruktive
und wichtige Rolle gespielt in der Frage
wie ukrainisches Getreide trotz der
anhaltenden Kämpfe exportiert werden
kann ich möchte dem türkischen
Präsidenten für
seine persönlichen Einsatz in dieser
wichtigen Angelegenheit ausdrücklich
danken es ist bitter dass Moskau dieses
Abkommen nicht länger
fortführt Russland verstößt mit dem
Krieg gegen eine lange bestehende
Übereinkunft das Grenzen nicht gewaltsam
verschoben werden dürfen das habe ich
als Zeitenwende bezeichnet denn es
gefährdet die euräische
Sicherheit gleich werden wir auch
darüber sprechen wie es um die Aufnahme
Schwedens in die NATO steht das
türkische Parlament beredt derzeit über
die Ratifikation der Aufnahme wir hoffen
auf einen baldigen positiven Beschluss
denn es geht darum die NATO als Bündnis
zu
stärken ein weiteres sehr wichtiges
Thema ist natürlich die Situation im
Nahen Osten am 7 oktober hat die Hamas
Israel auf barbarische Weise angegriffen
die Bundesregierung verurteilt diesen
Terrorakt der Hamas auf das Schärfste
wir werden gleich darüber sprechen wie
wir eine weitere Eskalation in der
Region verhindern können denn wir teilen
die Sorge vor einem Flächenbrand in
Nahen
Osten wer Deutschland kennt der weiß
unsere Solidarität mit Israel steht
außer Frage israel hat das
völkerrechtlich verbriefte Recht sich zu
verteidigen gleichzeitig sagen wir jedes
Leben ist gleich viel wert auch das Leid
der palästinensischen Zivilbevölkerung
in Gaza bedrückt uns seit Jahrzehnten
gehört Deutschland zu den größten Gebern
humanitärer Hilfe für die
palästinensische Bevölkerung wir haben
jetzt unsere humanitäre Hilfe in diesem
Jahr noch einmal auf mehr als 160
Millionen Euro erhöht und gehören damit
zu den größten Gebern humanitärer Hilfe
der gegenwärtige Konflikt ist uns auch
Anlass den Blick zu lenken auf die
notwendige langfristige politische
Lösung des
Nahostkonflikts eine Zweistaatenlösung
bleibt für uns das erklärte
Ziel lassen Sie mich ganz klar sagen das
Existenzrecht Israels ist für uns
unumstößlich und lassen Sie mich genauso
klar sagen in unserem Land ist kein
Platz für Antisemitismus egal ob er
politisch motiviert ist oder religiös ob
er von rechts kommt oder von links ob er
seit Jahrhunderten hier gewachsen ist
oder von außen ins Land
kommt und zugleich trete ich all
denjenigen entgegen die nun allen 5
Millionen Musliminnen und Muslimen in
Deutschland ihren Platz in unserem Land
absprechen wollen gegen solche Versuche
wende ich mich genauso
entschlossen meine Damen und Herren der
Nahe und Mittler Osten ist seit langem
eine Region großer Spannung weil es
unsere Nachbarregion ist kann das was
dort geschieht uns nicht gleichgültig
sein Herr Präsident dass wir zu dem
aktuellen Konflikt unterschiedliche zum
Teil sehr unterschiedliche sich Wasen
haben ist ja kein Geheimnis gerade
deshalb sind unsere Gespräche wichtig
gerade in schwierigen Augenblicken
brauchen wir das direkte Gespräch
miteinander Jenseits dieser akuten
internationalen Themen werden wir gleich
auch darüber sprechen wie wir in unseren
bilateralen Beziehungen und in den
Beziehung der Türkei zur Europäischen
Union konkrete Fortschritte erreichen
können in den vergangenen Jahren sind
wir in den Beziehungen zwischen der EU
und der Türkei hinter unseren
Möglichkeiten hinter unserem Potenzial
zurückgeblieben mit Präsident Erdogan
werde ich diskutieren wie wir hier
vorankommen
können Flucht und irreguläre Migration
sind ein weiteres zentrales Thema uns
eint das Ziel irreguläre Migration zu
begrenzen die Türkei und die Europäische
Union haben im Jahr 2016 eine wie ich
finde gute Vereinbarung
getroffen ich setze mich in der
Europäischen Union dafür ein dass diese
Vereinbarung fortgesetzt wird sie ist zu
unser beiderseitigem Nutzen und auch
über die Frage der Rückführung werden
wir sprechen
müssen die Bürgerin und Bürger
Deutschlands und der Türkei sind auf
vielfältige Weise miteinander verbunden
mir ist wichtig dass der Kontakt die
persönlichen Begegnung für unsere Bürger
gut und möglichst unkompliziert
gestaltet wird auch das werden wir
diskutieren das Erdbeben in der Region
gasianep im februah hat gezeigt dass
sich die Menschen in unseren beiden
Ländern besonders eng verbunden fühlen
so fort hat Deutschland mit
Bergungsteams geholfen ein Lazarett der
Bundeswehr bereitgestellt und den
kurzzeitigen Aufenthalt mehrerer tausend
Betroffener in Deutschland ermöglicht
für den Wiederaufbau haben wir
Finanzmittel zur Verfügung gestellt und
werden ihn weiter
unterstützen großes Potenzial besteht
auch in Fragen wirtschaftlicher
Zusammenarbeit den gegenseitigen Handel
sollten wir weiter ausbauen
Rechtssicherheit für Unternehmen und
eine stabile und wirtchaftspolitik sind
dafür wichtige Grundlagen sie sehen wir
haben ein volles Programm für uns für
heute Abend schönen
Dank
sehr gehehrter
Bundeskanzler gchätz Z
Mitglieder Werte Vertreter der
Presse darf sie ganz herzlich
begrüßen m ganz herzlich bei dem Herrn
Bundespräsidenten Steinmeier und bei dem
Herrn Bundeskanzler Scholz
herzlich danken für die
Gastfreundlichkeit
dieser Besuch auf Einladung von Herr
Scholz ist sehr
wichtig für mich und wir werden gleich
auch im Rahmen der bilateralen
Beziehungen der Gespräche die wir führen
werden natürlich die
vieldimensionalen Beziehungen besprechen
können dies bezüglich gibt es natürlich
wirtschaftliche Komponenten militärische
Komponenten aber auch die Entwicklungen
wenn wir vom russisch ukrainischen Krieg
sprechen und dann
natürlich zwischen Israel und Palästina
Ereignisse Entwicklungen auch diese
Dimension werden wir gleich erörtern ich
spreche immer ganz offen auch
hier denn 7
Oktober ist oder wird als
Anfang
dagestellt und das Prozedere sozusagen
auch
danach wird weniger dargestellt wir
sprechen von 13 000 Kindern
Frauen alten
Menschen die getötet worden sind
daneben
gibt es eigentlich fast überhaupt nicht
mehr einen Punkt den man Gaza nennen
kann alles ist dem erdboben gleich
gemacht
worden und jeder spricht von
Hammers von morgens bis abends auch die
Waffen oder die Kraft die Macht der
Hammers kann man das über vergleichen
mit dem was Israel
hat hat Israel eine nukleare Waffe ja
aber wenn sie Israel Fragen wird Israel
nicht ja sagen weil sie natürlich nicht
unbedingt die Wahrheit
sagen
und es wird immer davon gesprochen dass
man finanziell eine Unterstützung
gewährleistet Israel wird Hamas auch
solche eine Unterstützung gewährleistet
natürlich
nicht Palästina
die Unterstützung die palästiner
erhalten müss auch diese werden nicht
erteilt und in dieser Not ist es
vielleicht auch folgendes sehr
wichtig Gotteshäuser Gebetshäuser werden
zerbombt Kirchen werden
zerbombt damit auch
Krankenhäuser
obwohl neben
alem die Bombardierung von Krankenhäuser
das Töten von Kindern das gibt es in der
Tora nicht das können sie nicht auch in
der allgemeinen
Menschenrechtserklärung auch in diesem
Zusam kann man das nicht aber wie werden
diese und wurden diese Kinder getötet
wie werden die Menschen in den
Krankenhäusern
getötet und werden wir dort einfach nur
Schweigen werden wir unsere Stimme nicht
erheben und wenn wirsere nicht erheben
wenn wir nichts tun wie werden wir den
Preis dann zahlen in der Geschichte wenn
man dann zurückblickt und in
dieser
Psychologie
eines vielleicht dass man sozusagen in
einer schuldpsychologie sich
befindet darf man das so nicht bewerten
weil wir sind und haben keine
Schulden bei
Israel wenn das so wä dann können wir
vielleicht nicht so ganz einfach
reden
wir sind auch nicht eben durch
diesen Werdegang des Holocaust
gegangen weil der Respekt gegüber den
Menschen ist sehr wichtig und als ich
Minister Präsident
war bin ich ein Ministerpräsident
gewesen der ganz har Reaktion zeigt hat
eben wenn es um Antisemitismus ging auch
damals habe ich mich entsprechend
ausgesprochen von daher haben wir auch
bei niemanden Schulden Schulden auch
niemand mit
es bei unsere dieser Reise bei diesem
Besuch werden wir das natürlich
besprechen aber daneben natürlich müssen
wir
auch einen weiteren wichtigen Punkt
besprechen wie können wir das Problem
lösen also eine humanitäre
Waffen
Pause inwiefern kann die Türkei einen
Beitrag leisten Deutschland einen
Beitrag leisten und wie können wir diese
Schritte gemeinsam tun das ist wichtig
jetzt und sind wir bereit das zu tun
oder nicht nach einer W Stein nach
Israel reisen ich habe ihn
gebeten bitte die Sache von einer Seite
an wir von einer anderen Sache anderen
Seite an und versuchen wir gemeinsam
sozusagen diese humanitäre Waffenruhe zu
gewährleisten und wenn wir diesen
Schritt tun können wenn wir also eine
humanitäre waffenpuse
Waffenruhe Türkei Deutschland und andere
Länder wen wir das gewährleisten
können dann können wir das Gebiet aus
dieser schwierigen Situation aus dieser
diesem Feuer
retten und wir sind auch bereit
natürlich zu helfen wenn es dabei um die
Geiseln geht um die Rettung der Geiseln
geht
aber wie steht es um die Zahl der
Geiseln auf der anderen Seite in Israel
der
Palästinenser und was ist die Zahl der
Geiseln sozusagen auf der
palästinensischen Seite wenn wir von den
Geiseln zuletzt sprechen und in Israel
gibt es ja das mehrfache von Geiseln
sozusagen mehr oder weniger an
Palästinensern ein Großzahl die gefangen
sind momentan in Israel auch das müssen
wir sehen wenn wir das nicht sehen wäre
das nicht
fair und wir sind zu allem bereit zu
helfen genauso wie wir im Schwarzen Meer
im Rahmen eines getreidekorridors
vermittelt haben
und somit natürlich auch Europa Afrika
da haben wir nicht unterschieden das
zugute gekommen ist und ich sage ganz
klar und deutlich ein
getreidekorridor vom Schwarzen Meer und
das was dort gekommen ist ist so 40%
nach Europa od 14% nach Afrika 40% in
die Türkei und der Rest in die
Welt und es gibt momentan auch aus
Afrika wieder
Anfragen und Russland wird eine große
Menge an
Getreide
wieder nach Afrika schicken aber es gibt
gewisse Probleme was sind das für
Probleme ich glaube Simbabwe wird es
sein wenn ich mich richtig
entsinne dort geht zwar Getreide
hin aber das muss ja sozusagen zu Mehl
verarbeitet werden und das haben die
dort nicht da habe ich gesagt das können
wir machen das übernehmen wir als
Türkei wir werden das in unseren
entsprechenden
mehlfabriken verarbeiten und werden das
dann weiterschicken in diese Länder oder
in dieses Land also es sind Schritte die
wir tun müssen das übernehmen
wir und es sind vier bis fünf Länder
beispielsweise wo auch Russland über
diesen Korridor Getreide
schicken möchte und plant und wir wären
dann in der zweiten Etappe das heißt die
Umwandlung in Mehl dann soweit dass wir
das
Übernehmen genauso wie eben über
Russland eben die Türkei und Katar wir
entsprechende Schritte unternommen haben
das würden wir
machen und damit diese Schritte
unternommen werden
können
äh muss es zwischen der Türkei und
Deutschland auch diesen Schritt
geben und unser NATO Verbündeter
Deutschland
äh muss natürlich dabei auch mit
entschlossenen Schritten vorangehen wenn
wir beispielsweise auch diesbezüglich
von Rüstungsgüter und der Industrie
sprechen und den Export sprechen das
muss ungehindert möglich sein
wir wollen natürlich auch in der in mit
Deutschland in diesen Bereichen in der
Wirtschaft auch noch enger
zusammenarbeiten und wenn
wir von der türkischen Gemeinde mit
einer Zahl von 3,5 Millionen Menschen
ausgehen ist dies natürlich eine
menschliche Brücke die sehr wichtig ist
zwischen unseren beiden
Ländern um den religiösen Bedürfnissen
der türkischen Gemeinschaft gerecht zu
werden arbeiten wir auch gemeinsam an
der Ausbildung der tätigen
religionsbeauftragten ein weiterer Punkt
den wir besprechen werd ist natürlich
die
Migration und es gibt eine gemeinsame
Arbeitsgruppe die tagt ein weiterer
Punkt
wäre insbesondere natürlich der EU
Beitrittsprozess der Türkei ein
wichtiger
Gesprächspunkt und wir wünschen uns
natürlich ganz inigst das dieser
Beitrittsprozess weitergeht dass die
Zollunion modernisiert wird aber auch
die
Visaliberalisierung sind Themen wo wir
auch
berechtigte Erwartungen haben eine der
Motoren der Europäischen Union also
Deutschland und die Unterstützung
Deutschlands dabei ist natürlich für uns
sehr wichtig und das ist gar nicht so
einfach seit 52
Jahren wartet die Türkei an der Tür der
Europäischen Union
und bis die Visaliberalisierung
gewährleistet wird sollten auch die Visa
Verfahren vereinfacht werden
beschleunigt werden und auch das werden
wir heute besprechen sehr verhrte
Vertreter der
Presse wir werden natürlich das was in
Gaza sich abspielt sicherlich auch noch
etwas intensiver oben besprechen aber
wir als
Türkei sind stets natürlich von Anfang
an
gegen auf zivile Menschen gewesen und
sind es immer wieder und auch bei jedem
Gespräch haben wir das zur Sprache
gebracht und prioritär wäre zunächst
einmal eine
Waffenpause
und dass dabei auch die entsprechenden
Hilfsgüter ungehindert nach Gasa kommen
ze Flugzeuge voll haben die humanitäre
Hilfe zunächst nach Ägypten geschickt
und ganz zu
zuletzt per Schiff
Tonnen
Lebensmittel dann ein Lazarett oder
mehrere Lazarett wurden
dorthineschickt aber das Problem ist
natürlich das zunächst einmal das
fließende Blut gestoppt
wird 27 kranke Patienten und auch die
entsprechenden Begleitpersonen wurden in
die Türkei von El in die Türkei gebracht
zuletzt und gestern habe ich sie auch im
Krankenhaus
besucht und habe nach deren Wohlbefinden
gefragt und ich hoffe dass wir noch mehr
Patienten verwundete oder auch
krebskranke insbesondere Patienten in
unser Land bringen und dann auch deren
Pflege in der Türkei
von und hier ist es wichtig natürlich
eine
zweiaatenlösung nach den Grenzen von
1967 was unabdingbar nun erforderlich zu
sein scheint wir als Türkei
ist es unser Ziel ein Klima zu schaffen
ind dem Israelis und Palästinenser Seite
an Seite in Frieden und in Sicherheit
leben können das müssen wir schaffen
und hier muss natürlich jeder für eine
entsprechende Atmosphäre von Sicherheit
und Frieden und der Umsetzung dieses
Friedens Verantwortung übernehmen ich
möchte mich zum Abschluss meiner ausfung
noch einmal ganz herzlich für die
einlatung und für die Gastfreundschaft
bedanken und hoffe dass unser Besuch für
unsere beiden Länder und die Solidarität
aber auch für die Region Gutes bringt
vielen Dank
an Herrn Bundeskanzler Scholz herr
Präsident kann natürlich auch seine
Meinung dazu sagen die
Türkei ist natürlich nicht gleichgültig
geblieben gegenüber der Situation in
Gaza und hat Patienten in die Türkei
geholt das hat eben der Präsident gesagt
aber auch als Garant sozusagen als
Mittlerrolle der Türkei dafür ist die
Türkei auch da
wo der gesagt wenn es dabei um eine
Friedenslösung gehen sollte und auch die
Evakuierung der Menschen sozusagen aus
dieser Region Deutschland ganz voran
oder die Europäische Union was die
gedenkenen Sie zu tun in diesem
Zusammenhang zumindest wenn es dabei z.B
um die Evakuierung um Patienten um
krankke Menschen geht kann man da einen
gemeinsamen Mechanismus bilden was sagt
Deutschland dazu und Israel tötet alle
10 Minuten ein Kind in Gaza und das ist
natürlich beschämend im Namen der
Menschlichkeit
und und das denken sie dass Israel auf
internationaler rechtslicher Ebene
angeklagt werden
muss
also vielleicht ein paar kurze Bemerkung
von meiner Seite aus zunächst mal ich
habe es bereits in meinem Statement
gesagt israel hat einen
Selbstverteidigungsrecht es war ein
furchtbarer brutaler Angriff den die
Hamas gemacht hat auf Kinder auf ältere
auf friedensbewegte auf diejenigen die
sich für eine Aussöhnung zwischen Israel
und den Bürgern und Bürgern in Gaza z.B
eingesetzt haben auf feiernde
Jugendliche und deshalb kann es auch
nicht sein dass weiter die große Gefahr
besteht dass mit Raketen auf Israel
geschossen wird und das ist das was das
Selbstverteidigungsrecht ausmacht
gleichzeitig geht es natürlich darum
jede Chance zu nutzen die Zahl der
zivilen Opfer zu reduzieren und das auch
bei allem was man tut jeweils zu
beachten
entsprechend soll auch agiert werden und
für uns ist es deshalb ganz wichtig dass
wir uns einsetzen für das was jetzt
notwendig ist das betrifft humanitäre
Hilfe die nach Gaza gelangen soll wir
hab das sehr früh gemacht wir haben auch
dafür gesorgt dass es tatsächlich
gelingen kann und sind auch unverändert
dabei das zu tun wie Sie wissen ist
Deutschland ein Land das ganz vorne
dabei ist wenn es um solche humanitäre
Hilfe geht nicht nur jetzt sondern auch
vorher schon aber jetzt immer auch denn
die Zivilbevölkerung in Gaza ist ja auch
Geisel der Hamas die für ihre eigenen
machtpläne gewissermaßen die Bevölkerung
dort als Schutzschild benutzt wir setzen
uns dafür ein dass kranke Gasa verlassen
können und behandelt werden in
Krankenhäusern der Region aber auch
anderswo und da sind viele auch wir
bereit unseren Beitrag zu leisten dass
medizinische Behandlung möglich wird es
ist so dass wir unbedingt uns dafür
einsetzen dass diejenigen die eine
fremde Nationalität haben Gaza verlassen
können und wir setzen uns auch dafür ein
dass eine Möglichkeit best dass alles
dafür getan wird dass die Geiseln die
die Heras genommen hat bedingungslos
freigelassen werden darüber sprechen wir
mit vielen die Einfluss haben mit der
türkischen Regierung genauso wie mit z.B
der Regierung mit Qatar mit dem
ägyptischen Präsidenten und vielen weil
es eine gemeinsame Einflussnahme geben
muss die darauf hinwirkt dass die
Geiseln der hammas freigelassen werden
und damit das möglich ist haben wir uns
z.B auch im Europäischen Rat darauf
verständigt dass wir wollen dass es
vorher Pausen gibt immer mal wieder
welche in denen dann z.B die
geiselfreilassung stattfinden kann in
der z.B foreign nationals das Gaza
verlassen können in der humanitäre Hilfe
reingelangen kann aber das ändert nichts
daran dass die Notwendigkeit existiert
die
Selbstverteidigung Israels auch möglich
zu machen und nicht in Frage zu
stellen die nächste Frage glaube ich ne
als
zweitich
vielen dank Michael Fischer Deutsche
Presseagentur herr Präsident Erdogan sie
haben in den letzten Wochen nach dem
Terrorangriff der heramas auf Israel mit
mehreren Äußerungen für Irritation
gesorgt auch für Empörung gesorgt nicht
nur hier in Deutschland sondern auch bei
einigen anderen ihrer NATO
Bündnispartner ich würde da gerne
nachfragen wie sie diese Äußerung
gemeint haben zu allererst würde ich
gerne wissen ob sie sich zum
Existenzrecht Israels bekenn das hier in
Deutschland ja zur staatsron zählt ich
würde auch gerne wissen was sie meinen
wenn sie Israel Faschismus
vorwerfen und mit welcher Begründung
nennen sie den israelischen
Militäreinsatz gegen die Hamas
Völkermord und wie begründen sie dass
sie die Hamas eine
Befreiungsorganisation nennen die
hunderte Menschen in Israel ermordet hat
und die von fast allen ihrer natopartner
als Terrororganisation eingestuft wird
und Herr Bundeskanzler sie haben die
Verbalattacken des türkischen
Präsidenten auf Israel schon als absurd
bezeichnet sind sie wirklich nur absurd
aus ihrer Sicht oder gefährden sie auch
die deutsch-türkischen Beziehung und die
Zusammenarbeit mit der Türkei in der
NATO und was bedeutet das konkret z.B
für Rüstungsexporte der türkische
Präsident hat gerade gesagt dass er da
keine Begrenzung erwartet für
Rüstungsexporte die die Türkei wünscht
sich 40 € Fighter wird Deutschland
diesem Rüstungsexport zustimmen unter
diesen
Umständen
zunächst eine der vorrangigsten Länder
in der NATO in unter den ersten Fünf
sind wir als Land als
Türkei und in der NATO ist die Türkei
natürlich nicht nur irgendein Land ist
unter den ersten
Fünf und
in der NATO
egal welche Gesinnung welche Einstellung
und so
weiter ganz egal zwischen Russland und
der Ukraine
äh wer
ist auf der Seite der Ukraine alle und
wir aber sprechen mit der Ukraine
sprechen aber auch mit Russland
und unterscheiden auch nicht zwischen
diesen beiden Ländern in dem Sinne aber
33 Millionen
Tonn Getreide über ein
getreidekorridor haben wir nach Europa
nach Afrika vermitteln können das war
unser
Land und jetzt sagen Sie
hunderte und ich sage oder sie sag
hunderte ich sage
tausende
Palästinenser
werden oder wurden von Israel getötet
nicht wahr die Krankenhäuser wurden
vernichtet nicht W die gebetshäuse
wurden zerbombt die Kirchen wurden
zerbombt ich als
Muslim störe mich
daran sie als Christ stört es Sie nicht
dass die Kirchen zerbommt
werden und warum gibt es keine
Reaktion man müsste doch Reaktion
zeigen für uns gibt es in diesem
Zusammenhang in der Region wenn wir von
Juden von Christen von Muslimen sprechen
keinen Unterschied und das darf es auch
nicht geben und ich selbst bin auch
immer gegen sozusagen die Einstellung
wenn man eben gegen Juden wäre also
gegen
Antisemitismus bin ich gewesen der sich
eingesetzt
hat aber sie sprechen z.B von
Deutschland es gibt so viel
Unterstützung von deutscher Seite oder
oder Eurofighter ob jetzt wir das von
Deutschland aus bekommen oder nicht es
gibt viele Länder die Kampfflugzeuge
herstellen das ist ja nicht nur
Deutschland das kann man natürlich auch
von anderen Ländern
besorgen und Drohnen beispielsweise
undbemannte Hersteller von solchen
drohen ist die Türkei momentan auch ganz
vorne als
Pressevertreter sollten Sie uns damit
nicht
drohen fragen Sie oder stellen Sie uns
solche
Fragen die gewissenhaft sind die
menschlich sind und wo wir dann auch
entsprechende Antworten drauf geben
können vielen
Dank was ich vorhin auch schon gesagt
habe die Rolle der bei der Ermöglichung
eines getreideabkommens zwischen Ukraine
und Russland oder einer Vereinbarung
über den Getreideexport aus der Ukraine
und aus Russland war sehr wichtig der
generalvekretär der Vereinten Nationen
und der türkische Präsident haben sich
da sehr hervorgetan und noch mal das war
eine wichtige Vermittlung die dort
geleistet worden ist und noch mal ist es
sehr bedauerlich dass Russland sich aus
dieser Vereinbarung zurückgezogen hat
Gott sei Dank ist es mittlerweile
gelungen Getreideexporte aus der Ukraine
auch auf anderem Wege zu organisieren
das ändert aber nichts dass wir
unverändert alles dafür tun müssen dass
es wieder zu mit ander vereinbarten
Regelung kommen wie sie in dieser Black
Sea grain Initiative festgelegt waren
ich will noch mal den Standpunkt den
Deutschland hat unterstreichen der
Angriff der Hamas führt dazu dass Israel
sich schützen muss und sich verteidigen
muss können muss gegen die Angriffe die
dort von dort aus ausgegangen sind es
kann nicht dabei bleiben dass eine
Terrororganisation die diese Region
beherrscht von dort aus mit unglaublich
viel militärischer Gewalt immer wieder
solche Aktivitäten unternimmt das muss
ein Ende finden und das ist etwas was
ein Ziel ist dass man unterstützen muss
wir jedenfalls tun es und deshalb geht
es darum dass man gleichzeitig alles
unternimmt um die Zahl der zivilen Opfer
so gering wie möglich zu halten denn das
stimmt und das ist etwas was für alle
Menschen gelten sollte man kann keinen
Unterschied machen zwischen den zivilen
Toten die entstehen egal woher sie
kommen es muss wichtig sein dass wir
Mitleiden mit denjenigen die sterben
infolge des Krieges zwischen der Hamas
und Israel und das ist eine Position die
für uns wichtig ist deshalb also unsere
humanitäre Hilfe deshalb aber auch
gleichzeitig die klare Position dass die
von der massgenommenen Geiseln
freigelassen werden müssen ich will das
noch einmal unterstreichen für uns
jedenfalls bleibt es dabei dass es jetzt
notwendig ist auch für eine langfristige
friedvolle Perspektive dass die Hamas
nicht mehr in der Lage sein kann diese
aggressionshandlung vorzunehmen wie wir
sie am 7 Oktober gesehen haben wir sind
wie sie merken in guten Gesprächen
miteinander trotz unterschiedlicher
Meinung und das genau ist auch das was
richtig und wichtig ist in dieser
speziellen Situation denn es bleibt ja
alles dafür zu tun dass es eine gute
Perspektive gibt mit Israel und einem
palästinensischen Staat friedlich
nebeneinander das ist die zwei
staatenlösung die Deutschland die
Europäische Union aber auch viele andere
ja schon lange vertreten und die muss
die Perspektive der Zukunft sein ich
danke
Ihnen die
pressekonferen
ja und darüber spreche ich jetzt noch
mal mit hauptstadtkorrespondent
dominikepka der mir hier gleich
zugeschaltet ist das waren wenige Fragen
aber interessante Fragen Dominik was
denkst du wie hat Bundeskanzler Olaf
Scholz hier auf die ja doch sehr langen
Ausführung von Erdogan reagiert ich
finde das war ein Afron vor laufender
Kamera also Herr Erdogan hat sehr lange
du sagst es völlig zurecht geredet viel
länger als Olaf Scholz er hat die Bühne
sichtlich genossen und er hat Dinge
gesagt die Olaf Scholz noch deutlicher
finde ich hätte zurückweisen müssen Herr
Erdogan hat z.B davon gesprochen dass
Gaza dem Erdboden gleich gemacht worden
ist und er hat davon gesprochen er hat
auf die Frage ob das Existenzrecht
Israels auch für ihn gelte nicht
geantwortet also vor laufenden Kamera
Kameras hat Herr Erdogan auf die Frage
ob das Existenzrecht Israels gelte nicht
eindeutig mit geantwortet und Olaf
Scholz hat dann so eine diplomatische
Floskel gesagt man sei da
unterschiedlicher Meinung das hätte er
durchaus schon noch härter machen dürfen
erdogan hat immer auf die zivilen Opfer
im Gazastreifen rekurriert und Olaf
Scholz hat auf die Opfer durch die Hamas
in Israel rekurriert da hat man schon
gesehen wer von welchen Opfern spricht
macht damit Politik man sieht also das
kann man schon mal sagen einen sehr
deutlichen Dissens zwischen Olaf Scholz
und reep tayip Erdogan in Sachen Hamas
Israel und
naostkonfliktm was Erdogan ja auch immer
wieder betont hat ist seine
Vermittlerrolle am Schwarzen Meer jetzt
gab es ja in der letzten Zeit öfter mal
die Meldung dass man auch vermutet oder
weiß dass Erdogan sich so eine
Vermittlerrolle auch im
Nahostkrieg wünscht jetzt hat aber Olaf
Scholz vor etwas mehr als einem Monat in
Berlin den Emir von Qatar empfangen das
war ein Treffen hinter verschlossenen
Türen wie würdest du diese Konferenz
jetzt gerade oder diese pressebegegnung
denn in diesem Kontext
einbetten man hat gesehen dass Olaf
Scholz auf die Vermittlung von Herrn
Erdogan nicht wirklich wert legt was die
Hamas Geiseln
anbelangt Herr Erdogan hat sich mehrfach
als Vermittler wieder ins Gespräch
gebracht er hat auch gesagt dass die
Geiseln befreit werden mögen und dass
auch die Türkei dazu eine Rolle spielen
könnten er hat auch immer wieder eine
Waffenpause eine Waffenruhe ins Gespräch
gebracht und zwar eine dauerhafte und da
ist Olaf Scholz sehr reserviert gewesen
um nicht zu sagen ablehnend gewesen er
hat z.B gesagt dass man sich nur für V
Feuer Pausen eingesetzt habe immer mal
wieder also keine deutliche immer
währende Waffenruhe zwischen Israel und
Palästina und da merkt man schon sehr
deutlich dass es da Differenzen gibt
also die Vermittlung die hat Olaf Scholz
vor allen Dingen in Katar angesiedelt
vor einem Monat war ja der emier von
Qatar zu Besuch und hat auch einen roten
Teppich bekommen das waren auch sehr
schwierige Begegnungen sehr schwierige
Gespräche weil der Emir von Katar hier
links im Bild aus dem Auto steigt ja
eigentlich ein Finanzierer der Hamas ist
und auch durchaus Terror in in
Gazastreifen finanziert so der Vorwurf
und das waren sehr heikle Gespräche auf
die setzt er offenbar Olaf Scholz ein
bisschen mehr das hat man dadurch noch
mal deutlich gemerkt dass er die Avancen
Erdogans dann doch relativ kalt
zurückgewiesen hat
gerade ich habe ja gerade mal so ein
bisschen in unseren Chat geschaut und
wir haben ähm ziemlich heftige
Reaktionen aus der Community ich lese
hier so Sachen auf Youtube wie
unglaublich dass man denen nicht
ausgeladen hat wie kann die
Bundesregierung zulassen dass der auf
deutschem Boden der Art gegen Israel
hetzend dar auf gemeint ist Erdogan wie
hat man denn in der Hauptstadt jetzt im
im Voraus auf diese auf diese
Pressekonferenz auf dieses Treffen
geblickt das wurde ja durchaus
kritisiert das wurde sehr heftig
kritisiert und ich würde auch behaupten
dass nach diesem Auftritt die Kritik ein
Stück weit Wasser auf ihre Mühlen
bekommen haben denn Herr Erdogan ich
muss es noch mal so deutlich sagen hat
auf die Frage nach dem Existenzrecht
Israels nicht eindeutig mit ja
geantwortet er hat stattdessen von den
13 000 Kindern Frauen alten Menschen
gesprochen die ja wenn man so will die
Opfer Israels sein er hat aber nie von
den Opfern der Hamas gesprochen also er
hat auch nicht die Terroropfer der
Hamas genannt das ist durchaus eine
große Bühne gewesen für Herrn Erdogan er
hat auch Doppel so lange gesprochen wie
Olaf Scholz diese große Bühne hat er
sichtlich genossen um seine Israelkritik
um es mal neutral zu formulieren
deutlich zu adressieren und im Vorfeld
gab es auch große Kritik daran dass es
diese offene große Bühne gab z.B der
Linken Parteichef martin schirdewann hat
gerade auf dem Parteitag der Linken
noch gesagt dass er es nicht richtig
findet dass diese große Bühne für Herrn
Erdogan hier aufgefahren wird dieser
rote Teppich für Herrn Erdogan dieser
große Besuch es gibt jetzt auch noch ein
gemeinsames Abendessen und diese Kritik
ist glaube ich durchaus gerechtfertigt
die andere Position ist man muss ja
weiterhin im Gespräch bleiben
miteinander ähm diese Position ist
sicherlich auch richtig bei den ganzen
anderen Themen wie z.B
migrationsabkommen aber zum
migrationsabkommen hat ja auch her
Erdogan im Vergleich zu Hamas und Israel
relativ wenig gesagt mhm jetzt lag der
Fokus gerade eindeutig auf der Situation
äh auf dem Krieg im Nahost es wurden
aber immer mal wieder wier an der Seite
auch noch andere Themen angesprochen wie
z.B die natoaunahme Schwedens
der migrationsdeal
und noch weitere Dinge
wie z.B auch von Seiten Erdogans der
EU-Beitritt der Türkei wie bewertest du
denn diese Gewichtung die wir da gerade
gesehen haben der Themen ich würde
behaupten dass Olaf Scholz das wäre
meine Analyse insgesamt mehr auf die
breiten Themen gesetzt hat und für reab
Erdogan ging es vor allen Dingen darum
Israel zu kritisieren auf dieser großen
Bühne er hat auch die EU kritisiert und
durchaus damit auch Deutschland nach dem
Motto man sei ja schon seit 52 Jahren
vor den Türen der EU und werde nicht
reingelassen und er hat auch gesagt was
er will z.B für ein migrationsabkommen
da geht's nicht nur um 6 Milliarden Euro
ganz offenbar sondern auch um
visaerleichterungen das hat der Erdogan
schon öfters gesagt also er wünscht sich
visaerleichterungen für die äh Türkei
und dann auch schnellere Verhandlungen
oder eine schnellere Perspektive da sieh
sieht man mit welchen Erwartungen er
hergekommen ist meine Analyse wäre schon
dass das die zweite Botschaft war aber
die wichtigste Botschaft fürn Erdogan
war ganz offensichtlich noch mal
deutliche Kritik am Vorgehen Israels
nach dem 7 Oktober zu formulieren
vielleicht noch ganz kurz zuvor war er
auch im Gespräch mit dem
Bundespräsidenten mit frankwalter
Steinmeier Herr Steinmeier hat die Hamas
deutlich als
Terrororganisation tituliert diese
Formulierung Terrororganisation hat Ola
Scholz eben auch noch mal gesagt also
sowohl der Bundespräsident als auch der
Kanzler haben eine Äußerung von Erdogan
noch mal widersprochen dass also die
Hamas eine befreiungsgruppe sei und auch
der Genozid der Völkermord den Israel im
gazaastreifen angeblich mache das war ja
die Formulierung von Herrn Erdogan auch
diese Formulierung hat sich Olaf Scholz
nicht zu eigen gemacht er hat sie aber
auch nicht so deutlich zurückgewiesen
ich finde Herr Steinmeier war zumindest
was das Statement anbelangt von V ihm
haben wir ein schriftliches Statement
etwas klarer die Hamas als
Terrororganisation klar zu bezeichnen
und damit eben auch Erdogan in der Sache
zu
widersprechen vielen dank dir Dominik
für diese erste Analyse und dir einen
schönen Abend noch nach Berlin vielen
Dank und genau diese Äußerung die mein
Kollege Dominik hier gerade angesprochen
hat und nach denen auch der Journalist
fragte in dieser zugegebenermaßen sehr
langen Frage da ging es um
Faschismus den er Israel vorwirft es
geht um den Genozid den Erdogan in in
gazaastifen sieht über diese Töne
Erdogans wir jetzt noch mal sprechen
deswegen gucken wir uns die jetzt noch
mal
an Hamas ist keine Terrororganisation
sondern eine befreiungs und
mahedingruppe die für den Schutz ihres
Landes und ihr Bürger
Kft
[Applaus]
Israel verfolgt eine Strategie der
totalen Zerstörung einer Stadt und ihrer
Bevölkerung es übt buchstäblich
Staatsterrorismus mit einer Brutalität
aus die Zivilisten absichtlich auf der
Straße bombardiert nachdem sie gezwungen
wurden ihre Häuser zu verlassen und ich
sage jetzt ganz offen dass Israel ein
terroristischer Staat
ist
[Applaus]
ja über diese Äußerung Erdogans sprechen
wir jetzt noch mal mit David Bartel der
mir schon zugeschaltet ist er ist Leiter
des türkeibüos der Heinrich bölstiftung
guten Abend Herr
Bartel wie blicken sie denn auf diese
Statements die wir da gerade gehört
haben mein Kollege dominik hat ja schon
gesagt erdogan hat deutlich mehr
Redezeit gehabt als Z werten sie das
auch als eine Art
aff nein also da würde ich jetzt mich
nicht so lange dran aufhalten Scholz
hätte ja auch länger reden können man
weiß dass Erdogan solche Bühnen zu
nutzen sucht und auch zu nutzen weiß und
versteht und das hat er hat er
getan wir sollten auf die Inhalte
schauen dann lassen Sie uns mal auf die
Inhalte schauen es ist ja aufgefallen
dass Erdogan sich wirklich stark auf die
Situation im Nahen Osten fokussiert hat
viel über die zivilen Opfer im
gazaastreifen gesprochen hat trotzdem
waren diese Äußerung die wir gerade
gesehen haben ja noch mal ein Stück
heftiger wieso positioniert sich Erdogan
so stark in Richtung
Palästina ja er hat das ja nicht immer
getan er hat am Anfang nach dem 7
Oktober zunächst sehr zurückhaltend
reagiert in dem Sinne wie er es ja jetzt
im Statement auch getan hat dass zivile
Opfer auf keines Falls zu rechtig zu
rechtfertigen sein also auch nicht durch
die Hamas ähm weil er und er hat das
auch nicht zul deswegen getan weil hat
gerade vor kurzem erst ein ähm
annäherungs Normalisierungsprozess mit
Israel und auch in Person
des Präsidenten naho getan hat netanaho
ich glaube im Mai inor
getroffen in die Türkei also da lief
gerade ein ein Annäherungsprozess der
jetzt unterbrochen wurde und dann hat
Erdogan zunächst
ähm angeboten und versucht was er
tatsächlich jetzt auch noch mal gerade
gemacht hat jetzt sozusagen Scholz
Angeboten Vermittlung in diesem
Vermittlung sind Teil seiner
geopolitischen
macht Strategie
Ukraine wurde ja auch schon viel
angesprochen aber z.B vermittelt die
Türkei auch oder biet es an im Konflikt
zwischen Armenien Aserbaidschan in der
Region Teil von erdogansoltis Strategie
dieses Mal aber äh gab offenbar weder
bei der Hamas noch bei Israel Interesse
und gleichzeitig s der inen politische
dr mit in dem Maße wie die Zahl der
zivilen Opfer im gazaastreifen stark
anstieg und damit äh hat er dann seine
Position geändert und diesen Diskurs
ähm auf diesen Diskurs eingeschwenkt den
wir auch gerade noch mal gehört haben in
einer enormen Zuspitzung und zuspitze
ist eben auch Erdogans Erdogans Sache
er reagiert hier wirklich stärker
sozusagen oder spricht da eigentlich die
innenpolitische öffentliche Meinung an
die eben sehr sehr stark sympathisiert
mit der palästinensischen Bevölkerung im
gasin ja und zur innenpolitischen
Meinung in der türkischen Bevölkerung da
haben wir gleich eine Frage aus der
Community an Sie hier fragt jemand wie
hat denn die jüdische Gemeinschaft in
der Türkei auf diese Äußerung erdoans
reagiert hat sich der Alltag der Juden
in der Türkei seit dem 7 Oktober stark
verändert mm ja ich weiß da also ich
habe das nicht umfassend recherchiert
ich bin hier selber in Istanbul mal wir
haben ja hier auch eine ganze Reihe
Synagogen also zunächst muss man sagen
es leben in der Türkei gerade mal noch
20.000
ähm Jüdin und Juden das ist zwar die
glaube ich die größte jüdische
Gemeinschaft in der muslimischen Welt
aber es ist natürlich trotzdem
überhaupt nicht mehr die Zahl die noch
hier im 19
Jahrhundert so aber wir haben Sie hier
und wir haben sie und ich hab mal mir
irwann Mitte Oktober bin ich mal hier in
Istanbul hingelaufen hab mir die
angeguckt da war bisschen polizeischuss
aber
äh da sind die Botschaften die wir hier
bzw die Konsulate die wir hier in
Istanbul haben deutlich massiver
geschützt es äh ich weiß davon dass die
Schmierereien an der Synagoge in Ismir
das ist glaube ich die drittgrößte Stadt
hier in der Türkei gegeben hat von
Übergriffen gegenüber Judin und Juden
ist mir nicht bekannt
gleichzeitig aber
sind diese Menschen natürlich auch
verängstigt und werden sicherlich auch
vorsichtiger auf die Straße gehen also
sowas gibt es hier hier auch aber nicht
in einem Glück nicht in einem wirklich
wirklich Besorgnis
mm so viel also mal zu Erdogans Äußerung
und Statement zum Krieg in Nahost jetzt
ist Erdogan aber eine besondere Person
in einigen geopolitischen Fragen die uns
in dieser Zeit gerade bewegen und in
welchen er dabei eine Schlüsselrolle
spielt das hat sich unsere Kollegin
Brigitte spiermann mal für uns angeguckt
die Türkei hat eine Schlüsselrolle
Mitglied der NATO Schwedens Beitritt
hängt an Erdogans Zustimmung als
einziger in der Nato hat hat er noch
engen Kontakt zu Putin eine
Schlüsselrolle auch bei der Migration
das Abkommen von 2016 dass die
Flüchtlingszahlen verringerte liegt
quasi auf Eis wie pressbe ist
Deutschland angesichts der derzeitigen
flüchtlingskrise kann Deutschland ruhig
bleiben wenn Erdogan im Nahen Osten
[Musik]
zündelt ich habe das Gefühl Deutschland
opfert seine Werte Erdogan bestimmt die
Regeln die deutsche Regierung spielt das
Spiel in seinem
Feld ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher ist
das jetzt besser so so haben wir sie
besser
wunderbar sie habt's gerade gesehen
meine Kollegin heißt britter spiegermann
Entschuldigung für diesen Versprecher ja
sooviel noch mal zu Erdogans Rolle in
den anderen Fragen die uns geopolitisch
gerade bewegen und ein Thema bei den
Statements gerade war auch der NATO
Beitritt Schwedens Herr Bart wie
bewerten die den Erdogans Aussagen zum
natobeitritt na ja der liegt jetzt
beim türkischen Parlament und hat den
das Parlament hat den Ball gerade ins
ausgespielt und sozusagen auch die
zweite Halbzeit verschoben also es war
es gab jetzt eigentlich einen Termin wo
das im Parlament diskutiert und
möglicherweise auch entschieden werden
sollte das muss ja noch ratifiziert
werden vom Parlament die Entscheidung
der Regierung dem natitritt Schweden
zuzustimmen und das jetzt erstmal
verschoben worden und ich denke das war
kein Zufall sondern das war eine
bewusster Schuss ins aus denn erstmal
sollte das Ding weiter in der Schwebe
bleiben um Erdogan jetzt auch noch ein
bisschen politisches Kapital mit auf den
Weg zu geben nach Berlin das wird kommen
irgendwann aber Erdogan versucht das hat
er eben die ganze Zeit versucht bei
diesem ewigen Hin und Her versucht das
Maximum rauszuschlagen und er hat ja ein
paar Preise genannt die er gerne
einheimsen würde und mit nach Hause
nehmen würde ne und das Thema vis
liberalis
z. ist total wichtig hier ist zwar
Deutschland alleine kann gar nicht so
viel machen weil es ja um schengenva
geht also um die dann
euweit gelten
aber das ist eine Sache die hier in alle
auch die Opposition und die Bevölkerung
alle wirklich beunruhigt und auch nervt
und ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen uns auch
weil nicht mal wir schaffen es
Stipendiaten z.B nach Deutschland zu
kriegen rechtzeitig das ist wirklich
Problem
aber das ist eben für
erdan das andere sind
Wirtschaftsbeziehungen dann die
militärfeighter die hat ja der der dpa
Journalist auch
angesprochen möchte gerne 40 Euro
Fighter kaufen also da gibt's da gibt so
einige Themen und der natoeitritt ist
eben
ein Erdogan jetzt weiterhin im Gepäck
hat immer noch sagen kann also wir
können eine Frage die auch die Community
so ein bisschen umtreibt und die auch
Thema war wenn auch nicht so wahnsinnig
groß ist der
migrationsdeal da kam ja von Scholz
recht eindeutige Worte Scholz ist
wahrscheinlich auch nach dem
migrationsgipfel letzte Woche dazu
angehalten den wieder aufleben zu lassen
seit
2020 führt Erdogan den ja nicht mehr
wirklich aus bzw hat den gestoppt was
ist Erdogans Inter den wieder aufleben
zu lassen bzw was bräucht es
dafür ja das ist eben die Frage ob er
das Interesse hat den noch mal aufleben
zu lassen das Interesse wäre natürlich
sich dafür wieder gut bezahlen zu lassen
denn Geld braucht die Türkei sehr
dringend wir haben hier eine veritable
Wirtschaftskrise mit einer hohen
Inflation fortschreitenden Entwertung
der türkischener gegenüber den starken
Währung also Geld könnte er gebrauchen
aber Erdogan möchte diese Rolle spielen
und ich weiß nicht ob er sich da jetzt
drauf
einlassen das werden wir sicher in den
nächsten Wochen und Monaten erfahren
Herr Bartel vielen Dank dass Sie bei uns
waren und unsere Fragen beantwortet
haben schönen Abend noch sehr gerne
danke
schön ja sooviel zu dieser
Pressekonferenz mit Olaf Scholz und
Erdogan was jetzt aus diesen Gesprächen
folgt ich bin mir ziemlich sicher ihr
werdet es erfahren bei ZD fte und hier
bei f heute live vielen Dank für eure
Kommentare und euch einen schönen Abend
[Musik]
noch